nearest happy
happy Wednesday it really is a wonderful
Wednesday well unless you live in
Washington DC
then you're screwed
I mean in a nearly unanimous move
council members in the nation's capital
voted to soften penalties for violent
crimes including carjackings murder and
sexual assault
the upside well now the courts won't
have to deal with violent offenders they
can be free to prosecute gas oven owners
and it's about time
the overall the city's criminal code
includes reduced maximum sentences and
the elimination of nearly all mandatory
minimum sentences this is crazy there's
also Provisions that let violent
criminals ask for early release 20 years
into their sentences you know just in
case they were too stupid to demand that
they go to the women's jail
grow your hair out for God's sake so if
you're in a drug cartel maybe that
migrant bus taking you to DC isn't such
a bad idea after all they initially
passed this code in November but
Democrat mayor Muriel Bowser vetoed it
listen
anytime there's a policy that reduces
penalties I think it sends the wrong
message it's the wrong way to go wow her
insurance must have approved stem cell
treatments because it sounds like she
finally grew a brain
maybe she can lend it to our president
on the weekends
but this is the same lady behind the
creation of BLM Plaza TripAdvisor says
it's one of the 10 best streets for
getting beaten on a budget
my point being you could fool her with a
card trick true she vetoed giving
criminals free reign of the city but the
last time I checked thugs weren't
exactly being sent to their rooms with
no supper she was overruled this week by
the council which claims they're not
handing out harsh penalties anyways so
let's get rid of them so the ruling
might make her look moderate but really
she's as crazy as they are
here's how one councilman tried to spin
it well it doesn't lessen the penalty it
it lines up with what the Court's
handing out what people are are looking
at is that in on DC's criminal code uh
many many years ago there was something
added that added the possible maximum is
up to 40 years uh in prison for an armed
carjacking that's not something the
courts ever hand out
[Music]
you know I speak English in a little
Spanish but my Rosetta Stone lessons it
didn't cover stupid
if anybody here can explain to me what
he just said I'll give you a foot
massage and a lollipop right here right
now
Tyrus I don't want those
I'm just going to keep it to myself okay
but this is a penalty for armed
carjacking not having overdue tapes from
Blockbuster Video they should all be
getting the 40-year maximum the same
penalty they used at Blockbuster Video
attention Gutfeld writers
[Applause]
all right so the person who wrote this
Blockbuster joke what year do you think
it is
Blockbuster's last store closed in 2019.
let's try to keep the references to
things that actually exist you know like
kiss my grits and who shot Jr
I get those
anyway if these politicians are so
worried about protecting armed
carjackers at least change the name to
unplanned hitchhikers violent thugs have
feelings too
so why this change I mean look at the
stats on carjackings alone in DC in the
past five years they've skyrocketed 148
back in 2018 to 485 last year that's one
for every Twinkie and a Navarro eight in
that same time span damn
I always flapped
has anything been done to stop this no
they're actually doing the opposite
apparently woke politicians only care
about stolen cars if they still run on
gas
so since you're a gut felt viewer you're
smart and asking yourself self why would
the city council then want to reduce
penalties for a crime that's exploding
and because you're a Gutfeld viewer and
you're smart your answer would be
because they're [ __ ]
urgent a Gutfeld apology
I apologies for using a word normally
used to describe the cast of The View
I've had ease penalties for violent
crime well it's all about criminal
reparations apparently we must reduce
penalties against violent crime to make
up for years of Oppression you see
criminals are the victims and they
deserve damages for making them
criminals of course this is racist to
assume that blacks or any minority would
be like wow thanks guys you know I
wasn't planning to carjack someone but
now I might be
because apparently there are only
minority criminals and not minority
victims the D.C attorney general doesn't
even hide it tweeting reforms to DC's
122 year old criminal code passed before
women and black residents enjoyed
fundamental rights are sorely needed
this will this bill will improve Public
Safety and provide long overdue Clarity
and fairness in our justice system
I'm sure those words will be comforting
at the funeral when some Black Or
Hispanic parent is burying their kid who
was murdered for his Nissan
see it's not about safety it's about
retroactive Equity if they were victims
of the past you shall now be victims in
the future the new criminal code doesn't
even take effect until October 2025. so
if you live in Washington DC get out now
in your car instead of later in a hearse
[Applause]
tonight's guest he's had more people
killed than the clintons former CIA
operative and author of the new book
company rules Mike Baker
foreign
they stink and are full of parasites
the actor and comedian and writer Jamie
litzow
she's just like a classified document
often found on the floor next to an old
car
Fox News contributor captive what
and finally he eats his dinner off
tectonic plates my massive sidekick in
the NWA World Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
foreign
congratulations on your new book uh here
to tell us what it's about yes I would
and thank you for asking in this uh it's
uh it's called company rules it's on the
Scribd platform s-c-r-i-b-d which is the
Netflix of books as you know and uh the
whole idea is the whole idea is Hey look
it's an audiobook all right it's audio
it's an audiobook it's Netflix it's an
audio I don't know enough big words to
write a actual book right so right so
and but the good news for the for the
viewing audience is that I narrate it
myself I know that was my question
exactly and it's very soothing yeah even
though you say almost nothing yeah and
your sentences are a jumbled mess of
incoherence it's still soothing right
that's what my kids say all the time so
look it's it's all about it's not about
my time with the CIA uh it's about what
happened when I got out of the agency
with really uh a very limited set of
skills certainly not business-wise and
started and have kept the business
moving right and there were certain
principles that I took away with me from
the agency days that I think could help
people not only in business but in life
I didn't know I don't remember asking
what the book was about yeah okay yeah
do we have time for the rest of the show
no I think that that'll be thank you
everybody share and watch Fox
um
why what do you think's behind this do
you think that it my theory is correct
just say yes yes I do I honestly do
um and look I I can't put this any
simpler uh if you don't have
consequences for Action right you will
have increased crime if you denigrate
the police you will have increased crime
that is as simple as it goes and I used
to live in DC years ago for a brief
period of time it was poorly run then
it's poorly run now mayor Bowser tried
to do who by the way I loved in shanana
um tried to do the right thing that was
quite the cultural pull and uh but
people got that joke and they are
throwing up but no how many people got
that joke right yes
all right get to the point all right my
point is that you know even in the city
where the mayor is still talking yeah
did I tell you about my book I like went
away and I came back
now you know what it's like living with
me uh I'm done okay
Jamie does this inspire you to take up
carjacking because I know you're going
through a rough period right now I think
you're actually living in a car
so yeah honest honest to goodness um
carjacking it scares me just the whole
idea of it it scares me so much that I
fashioned my career to never be able to
afford a nice car yeah it's good good
for you I'm so worried about it because
you never heard of a bus jacking no
that's true that is true actually I saw
a bus Jackie once but it's like a
different kind of
um
could I say one quick thing about
Blockbuster Video sure do you know that
the very last standing Blockbuster Video
was in fact where I live in Fairbanks
Alaska that is 100 true and I remember
the last time I went in there because it
was the new the remake of Ghostbusters
had just come out yeah and I remember it
was up on the Shelf on new releases
remember those and it said if you like
this you'll also like and there was an
arrow pointing to a bowl of
I can't believe you took a reference
about something that does this and then
you did a joke on it because you had it
in your little back of your brain yeah I
have a joke about Blockbuster that's
what you did I feel like you can read my
mind
no one likes a joke about crime cat help
me out here what do you make of this
this is crazy do you think this is like
kind of the radical punishment of a
society that they believe deserves it
well I think carjacking is bad
I I mean there's I think that there's
you know plenty of laws on the books
that you know punish people for doing
something that maybe only hurts
themselves carjacking is not one of
those I don't think about a carjacking
I'm like oh no I feel so I hope that
person that did it gets to come outside
again soon like I don't know that
anybody's out there thinking about this
um so I think that no matter what you
you think about criminal justice you
have to be against when it comes to
violent crimes because either you know
it's going to be violence all over the
place but eventually then maybe that
pendulum is going to swing in the other
direction and we're going to have like a
super super strict police state so I
think everybody nobody should be
pro-violence except for criminals
themselves which we shouldn't be
catering to yeah you know but the thing
is Tyrus
they're not even ex like there has to be
a reason for this if every every
sensible person sees this as nuts and
yet they unanimously vote for it what
are we missing what if we if you do the
cognitive empathy and pretend you're
you're them how what are they thinking
well they explain the wrong things like
they say armed carjacking and no kidding
you need arms to jack a car that's
pretty basic like you can't you know if
you have a pistol in your hand people
are gonna get out of it like that should
be the key thing is they're they're
talking about very specific carjacking
that they're reducing the time for I
mean somebody puts a gun in your face
yeah and says get out yep and if you
better make sure the Tank's at least
half full because how irritating would
that be if you jacked a car and you had
to gas up yes you know what I'm saying
so
what it is is like when I was a child
you had to make choices like you would
say Mommy I want to be an outlaw and
she'd be like no if you become an outlaw
you'll go to jail
now it's Mommy I want to be an outlaw
pick mommy out a good one like that's
literally what it is now because there's
no consequences you can steal cars build
a career put it on Facebook and become a
carjacking influencer yes
and be just fine you know who doesn't
like this who uh new move by the city
council all the law-abiding citizens of
Washington D.C they are unanimously
against this move the criminals love it
but it it serves no purpose so I I was
just sitting here thinking about your
point and and you're right there's no
logical reason why they're pushing this
that's why I can't that's why it has to
be a punitive symbolic kind of thing
there's no unexpected people like when
you saw him in this little interview
safe in his office exactly he's saying
oh meanwhile the mayor has experienced
some form of carjacking yeah or someone
in her family or someone she knows the
unaffected or affected and as
Progressive as she is she does not want
any more carjacking yeah so she's saying
whoa hey no this is bad this is bad but
it hasn't happened to that group yet
right right and they probably don't live
in the city they need they need their
policies they need to feel the
consequences of their policies it's like
when the buses took the migrants to the
cities get these criminals to where
these people live so they know what it's
like that guy is the pr he's the poster
child the beta male white guy I knew it
was going to be a white guy before he
even said that yeah absolutely yeah
surprising number of them on the city
council yeah hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else